- Don't freak out.
Don't sneeze.
And just keep going.
(spooky music)
(hinges squeaking)
So, in about a few hours I will be doing,
what I've been told is a vampire facial.
I'm one of those people.
I'm like, "Oh hell no.
"Like that's fucking stupid, that's crazy.
"Why are people fucking
putting blood on their face?"
And then I got this little guy.
[ Retching]
But it's my birthday,
and I don't appreciate
getting a zit on my birthday.
So I was like, "Oh we are gonna put blood
"and all the shits on my face."
I'm right in front of
this place right now.
I'm a little nervous.
I'm a Latin boy from the city and I'm like
I don't know what all this shit is.
This is some rich people
shit up in here, you know?
Look at that, look at that.
Looks like science in there.
Alright, we'll see how it goes.
- I'm Dr. Shah and we're
here today at Next Health.
We're gonna perform a PRP
with microneedling on you.
- What does that mean?
- PRP is Platelet Rich Plasma.
- Yeah
- [Dr. Shah] And what that
is, is we actually take
your blood and we spin
it in the centrifuge
and then we separate out the plasma.
The plasma is a part of your blood
that has all the growth factors.
And we concentrate that up,
then we put it into your skin.
- Does this hurt?
- I'm not gonna lie to you,
it does sting a little bit.
- I feel like I'm about to get
onto a rollercoaster so I'm
like mixed with emotions,
my tummy's hurting a little bit.
- The results are really fantastic.
Some of the things that
the PRP really helps with
is acne scarring, pores, fine lines
and wrinkles, sun damage.
- How much does a procedure
like this usually cost?
- You know, the price range
is around a thousand dollars
for one procedure. But most
people buy a package of 'em.
- So I could like, skip a few meals.
Lose weight and get really good skin.
(Dr. Shah laughs)
- So you're ready to do this?
- Yes, I think so.
- Good.
- I'm scared. But yes, I'm ready.
- We'll take good care of you.
So let's go ahead and do this.
- Hey Curly, my name is Ross.
I'm a registered nurse
here at Next Health.
I'll be doing your treatment today.
First thing we're gonna do
is apply your numbing cream.
This is a blend of numbing cream,
couple different types
of Lidocain in here.
- Lather me up.
- Yes.
- I don't wanna feel a damn thing.
I feel like a cake and you're
just adding the frosting.
(Ross chuckles)
- We're gonna let this
absorb into your skin
for about 15 minutes
while we draw your blood
and prepare the plasma.
- I gotta look completely away.
- One, two, three, poke. Beautiful.
So now that we have the blood,
we're gonna spin it for about ten minutes.
We have the centrifuge right there.
And you just hang out and let
that numbing cream take effects.
Alright Curly, so your
blood is finished spinning.
This is what the tube looks like
after it's been centrifuged.
We have all the red blood
cells in the bottom,
white blood cells in the middle,
and then the plasma is at the top.
Now I'm applying your plasma.
This has all the growth
factors and nutrients
that are gonna really
beautifully heal your skin.
And then on top of that,
we're going to do just
a little bit of microneedling here.
And this is gonna push
all those platelets,
growth factors, and nutrients
deep into your skin.
You doing okay?
- It's not like unbearable.
Like I actually really
believe that you drawing
the blood was more painful than this is.
- You're definitely gonna have like
a red, sun-burned appearance after this.
It doesn't last very long.
About like a day, maybe day and a half.
Alright Curly, the
treatments all finished.
I'm gonna give you a little
peek of what you look like
right now.
- Alright.
- But this is not how you're
leaving our office today.
- Oh wow.
Poor face.
[Laughs Loudly]
- Not really though, not really though.
'Cuz this is gonna heal so beautifully.
Your skin texture's gonna be baby soft.
Your pores are gonna be so tiny.
Overall, you'll have
this beautiful radiance.
Now, we're gonna move
you to the next room.
We're gonna put on a hyaluronic
acid mask and do cryotherapy
and then we'll get you all
cleaned up and ready to go.
- Woohoo!
- Hi, I'm Vanessa. How are you Curly?
- Good.
- [Vanessa] How was your facial?
- I feel like my face is
throbbing a little bit,
but in a good way.
- Alright, so we're gonna finish
up the rest of the facial.
This is a hyaluronic acid mask.
Hyaluronic acid helps with moisture,
as well as plumping.
And it's also gonna stimulate
some collagen growth.
We like to do it with the cryotherapy.
So this is the cryomachine.
It applies about -15 to
-20 degrees cold air.
And the cold is what's
gonna have the skin react
in building more collagen.
- Oh, that feels nice.
What kind of life have I been living
that I don't know about any of this?
[Vanessa Laughs]
- Alright, so now
you're totally done.
- Wow!
- You're gonna look a little pink
for the next couple of days.
But that youthful glow is gonna be there,
and it's only gonna get better.
- Wow!
So we just got done with
the facial. I feel great.
I don't feel any sort of soreness.
I don't feel any sort of
tightness. I don't feel hinchado.
It just feels really good
and I highly recommend it
if you find yourself in a place
where you can try it. Definitely try it.
Let's see. We'll see how
I feel in a few days.
So it's super interesting
because I'm super red.
And I'm back at work and
people are trying to be
either really nice and
not say anything at all
about my face or they're like,
"Whoa! "What happened to your face?"
(laughs)
What do you think about my face, Gadiel?
- It's red, yo.
(Curly laughs)
- It's itchy as fuck, too.
- It's itchy? It looks irritated.
(Curly burps)
- It is itchy.
- Cochina.
- This is day two. You can't
really see in the light here,
but I'm still red. I feel
really tight and tender.
I've been wearing this all day long.
- He's complaining about
the thousand dollar facial
he got on his birthday for free.
- No I'm not.
I feel like my skin looks a lot better.
It's not like a crazy, drastic...
But, it definitely made me
consider taking more care
of my skin.
I think if you are gonna spend
that much money on a facial,
if you can, definitely do it.
Definitely try it.
It's not gonna change you overnight.
But I think it's the right direction
in learning how to self-care
and stuff like that.
(upbeat rhythmic music)